engloba tudo a trabalhar à tarde e à
noite acho que não é assim tomou não
posso colocar um jantar com ninguém mas
pelo som opiniões
a vale aqui para criar um caso a minha
experiência não só como alguém fez um
pouquinho para o curso cada típico mas
também como alguém que vem de fora
quando aparentemente o percurso
normalmente é o oposto
saindo daqui vão trabalhar para lisboa
não sei porque é que ninguém estuda cá
fica cá não conseguindo compreender mas
ainda estou a aprender a ficar pouco
tempo
é essa o percurso é eu estudei
administração pública
cheguei ao fim do curso pensei que não
queria ficar fechado em uma posição não
era isso que era pra mim e e tendo já um
homem anterior que era fazer páginas
internet ir aprendendo por mim próprio
resolvi que era esse o caminho só vi que
poderia ter motivado o horário sem isso
é uma vantagem
ia trabalhar em qualquer sentido eu
quisesse sair mais importante pra mim
até 30 anos nas ruas chega e fazer mais
as pessoas e fazia muito que nós brancos
e pra nossa cidade veículos mas é isso
que acontece
estava um bocado farto aquela confusão o
que eu decidi que seria um prazer para
mim sair dez anos aprender para mim
trabalhar nos sítios fez muitas coisas e
se concentra vez muitas outras coisas
enquanto estava a aprender ao mesmo
tempo também estava tirando ainda o
curso pode chegar ao fim já tinha uma
cauda um background do mar e completa
não é uma área propriamente fácil
coisas como aritmética binária não só
consegue facilmente assimiláveis no
entanto com muito esforço boa sempre foi
meu melhor amigo não usa regularmente a
greve começar a usar é eu sempre tive um
gosto enorme para aprender as que
estamos realmente cá para reunir
informação
e pronto esse desejo de aprender foi
mais forte
o percurso começou o vento que viu
algumas coisas que estou certamente
convidaram para fazer parte de uma
empresa era uma software aos elas rua
como saí fiquei um ano fiquei dois
começaram a aparecer coisas projetos
maiores com mais projeção estava em
curso começará por ser projeto com mais
projeção foi convidado por outras coisas
foi se desenrolando sempre tentando
aprender mais não é uma área que se
possa sair da faculdade e saiba alguma
coisa acho que minha mãe mas essa é uma
opinião pessoal acho que não sabemos nós
saímos da faculdade a saber grande coisa
podemos sim aprender a aprender isso
saímos da faculdade sabendo aprender é
uma coisa que nos dá grande grande
grande vantagem nem sempre acontece é em
relação a um curso de trabalho contínuo
começaram a aparecer as primeiras
propostas lá fora
recrutadores lá fora nós portugueses
somos muito bem vistos lá fora pela
nossa capacidade é mesmo assim o o
trabalhador irlandesas inglês americano
não é no entanto é altamente
especializado naquilo que eu faço é uma
equipa que está espalhada pelo mundo diz
libaneses turcos brasileiros e
argentinos portugueses também é servir a
alguém na minha equipa para fazer uma
coisa que não faz parte do trabalho
deles meu nome eu faço eu tô aqui pra
isso
é isso que o povo português disse
vamos ver o que vamos arranjar no
entanto esse coisas boas e coisas
mágicas e lá também especializados que
são altamente delicado coisa que nós às
vezes problemas um pouco numa coisa ou
outra para fechar projetos em questões
de taiwan e eu peça única no caso
português porque só tem como tópicos e
de mata só detalhe extrema
porque vila real não sair
não conheci villarreal brincar duas
vezes antes no lugar será por isso cada
plano de saúde do primeiro pelo design
desconhecidos que só não se conhecia que
nós aprender realmente só quando não
estamos confortáveis já se falou que
isso há que se dizer uma coisa
rita maria que vocês são os maiores
nada nenhum melhor exemplo do
desconhecido e no entanto lidam com
situações de alimento não só que nós só
estamos aqui hoje com elas de alimentos
não existem e ainda queremos dar a nossa
opinião a cia na embaixada das vezes nos
trata mal e isso é muito importante
volta a ser o cimento eo grande por mim
não tem nenhuma formação em engenharia
informática 0
eu sou da administração pública coisas
que me deram jeito lógica clássica uma
temática um caminho sim mas aprendi por
mim google muitas noites em casa
enquanto podiam sair para fazer projetos
que me propus a fazer para avançar
acho que só assim é que vai sair
empurrando pra frente mas eu já no caso
da moda de empurrar por empurrar a uma
confusão estava em vemos empurrar e
extrema importância avançarmos temos
também levamos hoje em dia acho que acho
que isso acontece 14 porque vila real
vão juntar a isso
a frase é a melhor coisa do porto
são certamente são mais flávio é mais e
quando uma pessoa fala do trabalhar
junto à noite no primeiro gol do porto a
não é fácil trabalhar em casa
tanta gente que pensa a trocas em casa
fazendo nada facilita nos pa
não eu tenho muita exigência hoje do que
tiver uma vez a trabalhar num posto fixo
trabalho muito mais mesmo pra mim agora
é a gente estava à hora o planeamento
que eu faço dos projetos é a hora agora
é muito cara custa muito dinheiro sendo
uma realidade completamente diferente é
eu tenho um projeto correr ao mesmo
tempo eu não conheço eu conheço muito
poucas empresas que tenham em portugal
11 projeto é é uma realidade que eu
fiquei pasmado eu próprio fiquei pasmado
já tenha contato com empresas suíças que
empresas na argentina fica realmente
pasmado não conhecia
procurai sobre a questão de procurar nós
estamos à procura 5 revela por exemplo
portugal não pagamos mal não conseguimos
encontrar a linha
por quê
há um impulso de enviar o currículo e só
não chega é preciso ter um fator
diferenciador é preciso que seja terá
descanso
eu posso dizer é que foi mesmo isso é o
fato de vencer vai fazer as canções foi
o facto de já ter passado
eu não ter tido medo anteriormente
passar por umas 50 salas diferentes
grupos americano photoshop saber fazer
eu estou comercial fiz muita coisa se
lança todas as coisas que nós fazemos
pequeninas hoje podem nos ajudar a
mulher não é só ir à faculdade e
acabamos o curso e vamos todos contentes
então torna se espera este ano acontece
acontecia no tempo dos nossos pais
isso hoje é alterado
temos que realmente ir à procura eu fui
à procura o link em tanta coisa que é
para usar tanta coisa está em jogo nessa
também a vânia neves está no porto estar
aqui
eu só vou mandar pra que eu sou o
sistema mais nada para escrever neste
caso fibra óptica nas caraíbas
não escolhi pra quem namorava teve um
peso no tratamento ela que votou
teve um peso você não quisesse eu não
vinha ela não eu vou dizer porque ela
estava a viver em lisboa
ela estava vivendo o mesmo é um
indivíduo ela ia fazer algumas outras
que saem daqui com mais voltas enquanto
eu estou porque eu encontrei coisas
talvez por ter um olhar em frente e aqui
um paralelismo que o cristo você que nós
quando estamos a fazer com ele muitas
vezes pensamos 10 horas ela mesmo com a
lei depois que teve a vez de informar e
ser melhor do que ninguém
nós às vezes temos 10 horas aula para o
mesmo evento a pessoa nunca viu aquilo
olha para os emirados e usava o problema
é que a senhora tem vícios é que essa
pessoa não tá habituado é passar dois
dias no mesmo sítio a ver as mesmas
coisas
eu escolhi aqui coisas a maioria de
vocês se viver e vila real as 57 que ela
nem olha pra ela pra mim são de extrema
importância na china uma das principais
entradas do livro o casal que é
registrado junto ao vivo traz 30 anos
disso o carro em casa no carro ou em
trânsito não vai trazer chegar lá
estaciona não tem que pagar para
estacionar nas ruas ativa financeira
tenha que estava sendo as províncias
deixar o carro delas foi um dia muito
dinheiro para deixar um carro prata
não é uma coisa prática ainda sobre o
curso surgiu a oportunidade de me
candidatar a uma coisa lá fora e não
acreditava e fica lá tentar os 300
pessoas podem até não acreditava estar
agindo com mestrado em informática etc
porque seria como escolher o nome
provavelmente porque já porque é uma
história
o texto do projeto que precisa conhecer
todo o processo
eles querem estar realmente em portugal
porque vêem potencial de portugal o
custo da carne mas bastou podem pagar e
geralmente depende do clã os próprios
vem cá porque estão a descobrir isto é
um rapaz lá que vai encarar agora vai
ficar com um amigo meu que também
trabalha conosco que é livre
preto e vai ficar cá primeiro perguntou
o que sabe aquele abraço explicando que
estava frito em contato com o hotel é
algo melhor pra nós é o que é um país
que tem como mil maneiras diferentes e
nós não damos valor nenhum
valorizo muito a opinião que não quer
uma coisa porque também nessa podemos
aprender mais do que 6 nós pensamos
nossas contas resolve nota não precisa
já vi isto não tem nada a dizer
não é assim que observar a vista muitas
vezes como as soluções que os outros são
de cobra e como um exemplo é só tem
portanto quem está a estudar e que não é
cá quando se quer ficar
por quê
alguém sabe a razão
9 a apra não o que querem e que não
querem ficar
é isso que estou a dizer é porque quer
ficar
o que falta aqui vamos emprego tamanho
que faça não compreendo
queria queria que isso fosse uma coisa
que nem todas essas mãos que baixaram
eu queria fazer uma coisa que faça
pensar em não funcionar em trabalho
mostrará por mim não dá para fingir que
funciona não é como mary campo maior não
é o que ocorre com a mala é dobrar o que
ocorre é pai também há muitas áreas em
que se é assim você não vai ficar preso
é uma licenciatura em geral
pra mim e à minha formação da popular
como formação pessoal com formação
pessoal com sites básicos em que ao que
me ensinou aprender sobretudo eu quero
deixar que este daí de que não estavam
presos a isso nem podem estar nos dias
de hoje não pode estar precisando
treinar da área
queremos deixar o time com algumas das
coisas que mais me surpreendeu na vila
real
o circuito
eu a carro o circuito sofreram bastante
eu sou e não sabia que existia de compay
segundo sofreu bastante
eu falo com pessoas em nova york dizem
ir pra você tem um circuíto quando vai
ao shopping mais pelo país pela pista
esse é loucura ficam doidos prá não
dizer nada
toda a gente tem uma opinião qual é
melhor isso foi uma coisa que me
surpreendeu bastante
agora a primeira vista possa parecer que
não mas talvez a noite quando eu quero
trabalhar fui dar uma volta cá porque
não consegui dormir logo eu trabalhar
caso da noite uma sala
não dá para chamar virar e entrar no
quarto de dormir duas coisas não
funcionam assim
normalmente é o tempo em que vão para
casa no carro e quer sair pra isso é uma
coisa que ao subir além do goleiro
foi uma coisa que me surpreendeu
bastante coisa tão simples
ao passar carro do piloto para a igreja
do largo para a encomenda que não sabia
que esse espírito é uma coisa tão
simples mas foi importante pra mim então
é importante que está aqui talvez amanhã
não vejo muita vai agora viseira gasto
médio já se viu
vilarinho grande barragem dos pisões
isto é brutal no caminho é só relva para
o cheiro do senhor dos anéis
quando achei um bom fazer a curva e ver
isto
eu valorizo isto estava a conduzir o
carro através do carro moto ou se
quiserem fazer essa estrada é uma coisa
espetacular façam isto num num sábado de
manhã num dia de sol
não foi nem mais
eu não estava caindo sequer fui com as
meninas da capa cestas cortez de quase
maio com uma tesoura um dia de chuva
trovoada é certa eu queria ter a
experiência eu queria passar bem por
aquilo
esteve lori alves lá cima das ventoinhas
aquela foi um acidente de carro
foi um carro foi o pé é difícil ficar
sair por bella
o carro ainda hoje que isto é uma coisa
extremamente importante
joão santo a uma coisa não está tão
perto da estação próxima ao rio é muito
de festa
isto é específico reserva foi uma coisa
que me surpreendeu bastante
taques no domingo pode dizer se é boa
não será vista pessoal mesmo
o embargo
outra coisa que me surpreendeu bastante
a coexistência entre a universidade e os
parceiros
os pólos universitários lá pra baixo mas
a semente não tem nada
vocês têm privilégio enorme de estudar
num sítio coexiste com o espaço verde de
uma forma brutal
reco